good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend
we can Friday Friday getting down on
stride that's right it is Friday it is
Friday congratulations everyone I'm so
proud of you you made it to the end of
the week and that includes you Jackson
hyd I'm doing well thank you so much for
asking I'm so excited that it's Friday
I'm so excited to be barking on the
embarking I love to bark I'm just
feeling identifying with the stress
Brethren who am I right who am I oh
a barker who am I Aurora rice who am I
con it's like whiplash
close who am I
talking about barking okay Travis Barker
yes I was playing the drums if you're
listening as a podcast I don't know if
you could hear my sick beat you probably
couldn't you probably could have said
sick but it was so sick but I'm looking
forward to embarking on the weekend with
Mike turdy here turdy's here for the
weekend all of your friends have just
landed we're recording a little late so
we apologize if this episode is up my
friends got here this morning they're
here for the weekend so it's just gonna
be like a fun-filled weekend we're down
the street is that the snatchers coming
to town as well it's a buddy it's a
buddy it's a buddy gang's all here and
no Leo would be here so like the
nibblings are here the friends the
aunties like my cup run is over your cup
Runners my Ray done mug runneth over
Jackie has already done mug this morning
it says cackle with delight which is
pretty much what we do what we can
guarantee every morning here at the
toast tackling the light I was also
thinking it's actually been a while at
least for me since I've you know um
flubbed on the toast like I haven't said
morning toast in a while like I feel
like I'm officially like out of that
phase don't jinx yourself I know I know
but it feels good yeah I I don't know
where I'm at I haven't flubbed my
intro a dude like I'm pretty much
settled yeah it feels good to kind of
settle in settle into the Rebrand so
like who we are we're meant to be yeah I
feel like Cruella when I stroke strikes
like this and with you're cackling with
the delight and there's literally a
witch's hat on the back how are you kind
of adjusting to your new home which is
covered in radon you have Ray done
everywhere I do so mugs I had cereal
today out of a ray done Bowl what bowl
it said snack on it that's not oh
snacking that's not Ray done it's pretty
fun it's very fun Olivia got it for me
as a housewarming gift like three
Apartments ago that's nice that you kept
it because I would have thrown it out
yeah it's a big bowl and don't put it in
the microwave because the contents of
the bowl won't get warm but the bowl
itself will get really hot interesting
too thick of a bowl it's really
interesting how like science works like
that maybe that's why if maybe it's a
snacking bowl and not a microwave Bowl
you want to put snacks in the microwave
I mean I would I would put it depends
what you consider a snack because for me
some things like that I consider a snack
others would consider a meal like mac
and cheese but I would put that in the
month oh no I think it's like finger
food it's meant for like popcorn
pretzels we're snacking we give snack
chicken I took a gorgeous trip to
Walmart yesterday we got such good stuff
I'm so excited about those Chesters well
let's talk about what happened to us at
the bakery section
we were Hoodwinked and Bamboozled like
you know I don't know if this is at
every Walmart but the Walmart we were at
when you walk in was like the bakery
section which is really kind of like the
most gorgeous thing it just like kicked
off what was it a great shopping trip
yeah so you know we're shopping for all
of your company we're hosting this
weekend we're gonna become a Hostess
alongside me I wouldn't say that but but
you have I don't want to Bear the
responsibility no no but you're already
doing everything so just take the credit
when so we just you know we wanted some
things you know to have around the house
things in which to snack and of course
what's better than like a fresh baked
tray of Walmart chocolate chip cookies
we grabbed it we didn't even think about
it we just grabbed it we grabbed it
trusting trusting the process yeah
cookies crab we spent you know probably
another hour at the store getting
delicious things we get home we're
unpacking we're unpacking one of the
very last things we're unpacking you
know first one and last one out
the chocolate chip cookies and I take a
second look at these chocolate chip
cookies and something just looks off
balance because there's kind of two rows
in this plastic container and one row
has five and the other row yeah she has
four
not five so I'm like that's weird I feel
like Walmart like
wouldn't like you know jip us of a
cookie and that's when we realize the
container was open it was a jar
and I guess we picked up a container of
cookies that somebody like literally
ransacked yeah like they were shopping
and I understand you know being hungry
when you're shopping it can be
exhausting I mean we got hungry but we
opened up a peanut butter M M's while we
were shopping we did and we took it with
us and we bought it and it's in my house
now right like like a decent civilized
we were sitting back on the Shelf tape
it up and expect someone else to buy it
they didn't even tape it up no they
didn't even close it all the way they
didn't even close it off so anyways like
someone's Paws wearing our cookies no we
had to throw away the whole thing which
is such a [__] waste you don't know
where people's hands have been in this
climate in this economy woof we can't
just be like eating finger cookies no it
was so upsetting and thank God we are
the way that we are that we also bought
a lot of backup some Entenmann's a
sealed box of enderman's chocolate
cookies which are better I don't care
how good the Walmart cookies were gonna
be you have never given me a chocolate
cookie that's better than an entenman's
chocolate chip cookie I feel like we
talk about it you know semi-annually
yeah so thank God for the backup because
last night like I needed a sweet treat
and I went in for the Entenmann's but it
was so it was like kind of humanity at
her because we like and then Zach was
like well why didn't you check when and
it's like we are trusting women no we
trust the process we're good in people
to not do such a thing it wouldn't even
cross our minds it wouldn't even cross
like to be honest like I know that there
are people who like snack while they
shop and then like don't pay for like
the little bag of chips like okay that's
a victimless crime you know this is not
a victimless crap we are the victims
we're the victims yeah not cool
not cool
so we're down to a couple cookies but we
got some other snacks to tide us
Chester's we love Chester Entenmann's I
have like some snacks that like I eat
with my friends because like we used to
eat them in college so like when we get
together we eat them one of them being
Mesquite barbecue chips they've gotta be
Mesquite God I don't mind barbecue chips
they're not my favorite but I don't mind
them we ate them all the time also like
the special dark pretzels but they
didn't have them at Walmart Pizza Bagels
um so I had to get those key items no we
really kind of like stacked the pantry
yeah it was a lot of work there were
highs there were lows clearly but I'm
glad we did it yeah because now maybe
we'll have a nice big lunch yeah I love
lunch me too
um
so this is kind of what's new with us
yeah it was really big day
huge what else did we do yesterday I
think we were so busy
we had meetings we had a really good
meeting where we you know they told us
you guys like are the best people
yeah they were just like pretty much
like keep doing what you're doing they
were like girl you'd be killing them
what song is that I don't know you're
not kidding them go best friend we
killing it no new friends that's us so
just kind of like an amazing start to
the weekend hope you guys have some big
fun weekend plans and let Usher you
that's what we're here to do we're
pretty much sure we're Usher you know
yep if you want more scream it out
louder that's Usher no okay that's like
not the song like people would say like
for Usher it's
these are my confessions sure sure
that's these are our confessions but we
want more screaming I think that's Usher
I don't even know the song that you're
singing such a good song and watch How
It's not Usher
sing it again
if you really want more scream it out
louder sounds good get on the floor
bring out the fire and then light it up
hey
gonna push it to the Limit give me more
it literally sounds like a song from
that Corbin Bleu Disney Channel original
movie gotta push it push it to the limit
limit cause we're in it to win it we're
in it to win it oh yeah okay uh shares a
song called more may I just check to see
if it's right yeah of course I didn't
just like humiliate myself oh and
there's remixes that's totally it
the red one remix
don't play for more than seven seconds
we'll get like what we can't monetize
[Music]
toast radio baby
you know what I don't work out
but if I did
I would be like [__]
popping it to this song
it's so good I Can't Stop Dancing so
good we put it closer to my adventure
[Music]
in the mirror I need to Shazam and add
to my
to my workout playlist which I don't
even have
anymore
oh we gotta hit the clubs
[Music]
oh
when that bass comes in okay I'm tired
so good
that just like reminds me there's like
four songs in this universe that like if
I ever really needed to work out like I
would listen to and that is gonna be one
of them so good weirdly another one that
like makes you actually want to go for a
jog is
um
so let's get up let's get on it don't
you leave me broken hearted tonight it
has like such a perfect like um maybe if
you're on the treadmill it has like the
perfect BPM for you like walking I'm
adding it to list of favorite stories
talking about that song it is and the
bpms oh it is
years ago did a toast radio which was a
concept that we did for patreon which is
the most amazing brilliant idea in the
world that was very divisive because
some people said like they just didn't
want to be
hearing music from us like instantly
instead of hearing us but first of all
the concept was this it was like we had
an hour-long radio show where we were
talking in between songs we were
introducing songs and each toast radio
we only did like three had a theme there
was a holiday we did a January like
motivational toast radio songs that will
make you want to get up did you put that
one on it no but you put brokenhearted
and talked about the BPM it's literally
the perfect BBM so if you want like a
radio show to listen to like on your way
to the gym go to patreon.com search
toast right radio and find that January
episode it's filled with songs that will
make you want to do things I'm like
still so mad at the divisive nature of
toast radio because I thought it was
like the best idea and it was
like I just thought it was amazing and
people were like toast radio sucks like
every time you do it it was so hot
button so polarizing so polar I think it
was actually like a lot of work for us
so it wasn't like we when people when we
couldn't do it anymore it's like okay
fine right because it was like tortured
a stitch together like all that audio
all the audio all the volume yes
um it was like 10 songs total but like
people didn't like don't tune into our
episodes to hear 10 songs they were
wrong they were wrong because it's the
best idea it's like you know we were
like Elvis Duran
zoo and the toast morning Zoo because
we've got a literal zoo in this studio
oh my God that was I'm like triggered
again talking about toast radio go enjoy
it at least like that was a moment in
time a lot of things that we've done
like are you know forever some things
are just a moment in time go and enjoy
toast radio because we put our Heart and
souls into that yeah there's like three
episodes and they live in perpetuity at
patreon.com
um okay well I feel like we should dive
in because the sooner we start the
sooner it's the weekend for everyone you
know
so true so without further Ado did it do
here are the past five stories that you
need to know and today's episode is
brought to you by Clinique many things
can dehydrate your skin including
weather pollution blue light time spent
in the sun mask wearing air travel air
conditioning days in the Sun
fight back against lifestyle dehydrators
with the Clinique Moisture Surge 100
hour this supercharged gel cream
hydrator delivers 100 hours of hydration
for plump glowing skin even after
washing your face Auto replenishing
technology helps skin create its own
internal water source delivering
continuous oil-free and non-greasy
radiant hydration after one week 99 of
women say that it leaves their skin
feeling deeply hydrated so the oil-free
gel cream moisturizer has aloe by Furman
NHA complex and it penetrates deep into
your Skin's surface for 100 hours of
stabilizing hydration Plus Auto
replenishing technology that helps
create its own internal water source so
it'll continually rehydrate itself and
lock in the moisture your skin will feel
soothed with hydration in three seconds
and it keeps on glowing it is winter you
guys we are not [__] around when it
comes to hydrating our skin and Clinique
is a brand you can trust it's a brand I
feel like a lot of our moms use like
it's been around forever for a reason
they are a staple in the beauty
Community this moisturizer I have been
having the worst most cracked crusty
skin in especially when I'm in New York
because it's so cold and investing in a
good moisturizer will make such a
visible difference in your skin after
one application there's 174 boost in
hydration there's an immediate
improvements in skin Radiance and your
dehydrated skin is smoothed and
comforted with a nourishing hydration so
you can use it alone or under makeup on
any dry spots you can use it as a five
minute mask as a cuticle treatment a
frizz fighter just one use and you'll
see Improvement in skin Radiance shop
Clinique's Moisture Surge 100 hour this
Valentine's Day for 20 off at
clinique.com the discount is valid
through February 14th AKA Valentine's
Day Valentine's Day Happy Valentine's
Day 30. can I ask you a question
will you be mine I'm always here 100 how
does it feel to have a turd as your
Valentine
damn it flipped on me yeah it flipped
yeah I have a turd as a business partner
it's so true you have a turn as a
roommate right now it's actually so
crazy like how little I'm bothered by
being called to turn on a daily basis
and I feel like that's something like as
a teenager over there you should call me
a 10. yeah no word like that would be
like you would put your foot down like
this nickname is not right this can but
for me like I don't think I'll ever
really have a problem with a nickname
like as long as people are talking to me
like I'm just great as long as you're
the turd on everybody's lips
ew what you're disgusting I cannot
believe you made that joke that's
something I would say
no it's too good wait it's too good to
pass up we made a tick tock yesterday
um and we need to talk about the
discourse Around The Tick Tock what are
they saying about me that I'm fat oh my
God stop because they're so junkie so
The Tick Tock is that sound from Keeping
Up with the Kardashians can I give you a
big hug and Courtney's like uh no thanks
so it's like so me and Jackie like
Jackie does not like to be touched and
so we're like kind of going viral but
the comments people are like I would
have thought it was the opposite like
what Jackie loves to hug and Claudia
hates what girl I am so affectionate
that's just probably the vibe that
they're getting from our Tick Tock
because we're like we're different
people on Tick Tock than we are like the
real ones know I guess but maybe the
tick-tockers like thought oh Jack yo
she's Genji Z's big sister like she just
wants to give everyone a hug but like
what if I do I give off that would make
people think I don't like to be hugged I
feel like I'm always always like talking
about how much you hate everyone and
everything oh I guess yeah but once you
know us like you know yeah Jackie hates
and I just feel like my Tick Tock energy
you know even if you look at my perfect
moment in time of a tick tock page like
I'm the camper like I just I want the
counselors like I you would think I
would love affection that's just like
the kind of my brand on Tick Tock well
your Tick Tock definitely got like a lot
of action last night because I tagged it
and um
and my our video together like got like
250 000 views so people were like oh my
God khakis Tick Tock is not real so I
bet if you were to log in which I know
you can't you don't know how
um you would have like tons of
Engagement what's so funny is Olivia
sent me a video from my Tick Tock last
night just um just a perfect video of
mine and I was like it's Perfection and
she was like your Tick Tock is hilarious
and I was like yeah I don't even care
that I can't get back in there because
like what should I do like now that I'm
a big house for out I don't I shouldn't
be on the same page as that girl no like
if you it really is it's like a time
capsule almost yeah just leave it so
like this shouldn't be with that okay
what about we're stopping the negative
self-talk for real oh that's true but
like it was it was literally four years
ago like it's it's fine to put Stone
evolved but it's time to evolve but stop
like for real evolution is so toxic okay
but like now you're being mean by like
telling me to stop being mean you know
what I mean yeah no I'm like getting mad
at you for being mad you know yeah and
it's like it's just more harm
okay calm down calm down okay the harm
is coming like from inside the house the
arm the harm is kind of constantly
coming from inside the house yeah
so you don't have your iPad I do have my
iPad it's right here um now I'm tempted
to just like go look at my Tick Tock
quickly from my fake talk that I
literally never use except today I
wanted to watch something that a video
you're checking your Tick Tock right now
we're in the middle of course I just
want to see how she's doing we're just
in the middle of work and like maybe one
of my videos is going viral we're
literally in the middle of work this is
something I would do okay I'm still
under 50K so like not that much
48.5 okay respectable yeah but no none
of them like hit a million overnight or
something oh I could have told you that
they that they didn't yeah sure
um okay so let's say then are you ready
for our first story yeah a little
romantic news Vanessa Hudgens is engaged
to professional baseball player Cole
Tucker so happy for her Vanessa Ann
Hudgins is engaged her boyfriend Cole
Tucker people can confirm TMZ was the
first to report the news saying the pair
got engaged at the end of 2022 people
have reached out to their reps for
comment no comments so far they first
sparked dating Rumors in November 2020
they when they were seen holding hands
in LA
the pair met on a zoom meditation group
call and Hutchins later revealed that
she made the first move on the Drew
Barrymore show she said I get on the
zoom meditation group call and I'm like
who is that I found him and we started
talking if I want something or someone
I'm going after that I bully just slid
into his DMS and was like hey it's nice
to meet you so I think there's no shame
in making the first move they started
dating made their red carpet debut at
the premiere of her film Tick Tick boom
that's another good song to
you know that tick tock song
everybody's talking about it I don't
even know yes you do it's like is it
from Tick Tock no it just like came out
at the same time you know just like
other coincidence coincidence yeah like
the Snow White movie can I say I'm so
happy for Vanessa and I feel like I wake
up every day and I just hope that
Vanessa Ann is doing well and that she's
happy and I feel like you know obviously
she's engaged so she's doing well and
she's happy and it's just such a joy too
to know that you know I feel comforted
of course you know one can't help but
think that this should have been her and
Austin Butler but the way I'm like
starting to hate Austin Butler
um and I just want Vanessa to have
happiness so I feel good about this even
though he's like it's not like like my
type you know yeah but you know what it
doesn't matter does he have like a big
contract you know that's what matters he
plays for the Reno Aces is that like a
D-League it doesn't sound like the major
leagues but they called him an MLB
boyfriend they did even though I do
think if even if you're on like a
D-League team you're still like an MLB
player no you're not they're a minor
league baseball team on the Pacific
coast league and the AAA affiliate of
the Arizona Diamondbacks oh okay so I
guess if he ever goes up he goes up to
Arizona
um it's not great let's let's be honest
it's not great it's not great no but
like that's how much she must love him
so think about the love yeah I do also
often think maybe he's like slated to go
to the MLB maybe this is I don't know
how baseball works like if it's like the
NFL not like there's not a draft I don't
think like maybe you spend your time in
the minor leagues like you improve and
you and you hit the majors no I think
it's actually really similar to
basketball in the sense that like once
you get to them like
either you start out in the minor
leagues or you get like demoted to the
minor leagues you know
yeah it could be the beginning or the
end let's see his age
26. okay
it's like average and they didn't say
MLB player they said professional
baseball player so intentional with
their wording yeah you've got to be I
just I do often think about Vanessa
Anne's financial situation she doesn't
like work that much no but she's always
in like a movie here and there she's got
something going on she was in Tick Tick
boom yeah and then before that what
spring break those Princess Diaries okay
you're right you're right you're right I
feel like any time she's like oh I like
that purse put me in a movie yeah
because I like that house yeah yeah and
she could always get a gig if she's
looking for one and she was in rent live
true no she was also in grease live she
was Rizzo she wasn't rent yes she was
she was yeah she was amazing she put the
whole show on her back because that guy
hurt his foot oh well she was also in
grease live yeah cause she's a live
Queen she is she's super talented I love
her she should work more yeah she's
really talented I'm happy for her do I
wish she was a major league I do but you
know what
Beggars can't be choosers yeah she was
who did she play in rent live she played
Mimi
let's go
tonight you should watch some videos of
her performance I should she was amazing
well the performance that she gave in
Greece was even more amazing because her
dad had passed away like two days prior
and she still did it she gave it her all
and she had this like really emotional
solo that was like obviously emotional
in real life too it was beautiful yeah
I'm happy for her I really am I love her
me too and I like the story of how they
met I also feel like she's like a really
fun celebrity you know like she I feel
like she's a celebrity I could be
friends with yeah like when she goes out
she's actually having a good time yeah
and she's like is it a good girl's girl
and she's like actual friends yeah not
like fair weather party friends I'm like
her Instagram is real and it's run by
her and it's like real photos of her
life it's not just like always pictures
taken on a professional camera remember
when she posted a photo of her in Austin
Butler and guarding engraving their
initials in a tree and it turned out it
was like in a like a Historic Park and
they got sued yeah that was funny you
hate to see it you do hate you hate to
see somebody designating Jessica a
national park you that you really do
disgusting they were wrong for that they
were but at least it wasn't intentional
and at least they learned their lesson
they had to pay that fine it was pretty
big yeah and I think we all learned a
lesson do not carve your name in a tree
at a historic National Park but you also
never know what tree is historic and
that you can't desecrate so maybe let's
just not desecrate them like they didn't
even know that it was bad they were so
proud they like took a photo of it yeah
yeah exactly are you ready for our next
story which is a little more love news
Portia de Rossi surprises her wife Ellen
DeGeneres with a vow renewal and
re-wears her wedding dress
Ellen and Portia celebrated their
wedding anniversary early with the
surprise baroneural I'm surprised what
uh it's a I don't know it's a lot of
syllables yeah renewal try it the
renewal thou renewal well when you say
it like that yourself
[Laughter]
on Tuesday the couple in a group of
their loved ones gathered for what most
thought was a 50th birthday for Porsha
yet the celebration turned into a
romantic ceremony commemorating their 14
plus years of marriage and officiated by
their close friend Kris Jenner Queen in
a video shared to The Ellen Degeneres
shows YouTube channel Porsha walks
through their home re-wearing the
gorgeous sack pose and wedding dress
from the couple's 2008 nuptials it's
really not my favorite dress like by any
means I didn't like it back then and I
didn't like it now this is cute
um
wait I had something negative to say
just I can't remember what what element
of it it's a cute concept yeah and I
feel like if I didn't see the video I
would be more into it but it was just
like I'm glad it was at least her
birthday party she wasn't making like
Ellen's birthday about her like she can
spend her birthday however she wants
yeah like she just like came out like in
a big dress and
it's a lot no it was giving like sweet
16 quinceanera like Bat Mitzvah Vibes
like how do you run outfit change yeah
yeah it was a lot but like I do think
that their love is like so real and
they've been together so long and like
renewing their vows you know when you're
not a real housewife is a really
beautiful that's what I was gonna say
thank you
it's about the video that I saw in like
the part
she walked out in this big dress and
everyone was just like what it was
giving
lost wife Affair like it was giving like
kind of like staged really awkward
um ill-prepared energy but I hate to be
so negative yeah like just gonna help it
do you ever feel and I mean you and Ben
have been married how many years five
going on sex do you ever feel like
you'll be in a place where you want to
renew your house okay no but I know what
you want to do I want to have another
wedding because I got married so young I
was so ugly I like hated everything
about them self-talk harm it's not by
the way the thing is it's not self
negative self-talk but it's true okay
okay that's what I'm gonna tell you to
you next time by the way what you were
saying was not true think screen but I I
would like to in I would like to throw
another wedding not a Val renewal just
like another big fun party like seated
dinner like wedding Vibes where I wear
white and everybody is dressed in black
tie but it's not like a wedding
um would you do another ceremony no okay
so really not a hour in a row like an
anniversary party an anniversary party
that's a wedding that's a wedding yeah
theme yeah like I wear white and
everybody Wears Like gowns I love that
for you and I feel like that's much
different than of our novel because your
intentions and like your reasons for
wanting to do it are completely
different like she's literally wearing
the same dress you would be doing it to
wear different oh my God I couldn't be
me unless I do the anniversary party and
then 10 years later after that then I
come out in the anniversary dress yeah
but I like your wedding dress I actually
do like my wedding dress too it was very
pretty
um the girl wearing it wasn't I actually
think if you chose a wedding dress now
it wouldn't be that different from what
you chose completely agree
cool I love agreeing with you it's the
best what else is there to say when
we're agreeing in such agreement yeah no
it's good yeah
um so
I'm happy for their love Chris
officiated you know Harry and Megan were
there rumored rumored yeah I didn't see
any videos or pics of them but I did see
Chris
um Chris and Ellen's relationship is
like so crazy I know when they used to
all go on The Ellen Show I'm like oh
they have a good working relationship
with Ellen and then as Ellen like you
know weaned into retirement
you really realize like they're actually
so close like she was on Kardashians I
feel like they take a lot of trips
together they're like besties and like
for Chris to be the one to officiate
right Gwyneth Paltrow was there Jennifer
Connor Aniston Carol Burnett Courtney
Cox Katy Perry Melissa Etheridge Orlando
Bloom wow Miranda Kerr followed me back
on tick tock
she follows me on Instagram and then I
followed her on Tick Tock and like I
don't know how she saw little on me
exactly yeah that is exciting she had a
tic Taco Barrel like her second one ever
it was about like when you love your
son's stepmom the one I was telling you
yeah yeah cute she deserves it I love
her I'm like obsessed yeah you're in
your career yeah by the way I've been in
my career era for a while because I'm
obsessed with like her fairy tale life
like without Spiegel her story but she I
think she might be one of our OG
examples of a businessman Bo yeah I
think we maybe even came up with
businessman Bo talking about Miranda we
came up with businessman Beau well we
didn't come up with it it was the
tabloids who call everyone a businessman
right but I think it started with
Camille Grammer a million years ago she
got a businessman bow and we were like
everybody needs a business in rainbow
look it up and we're under curve yeah
okay but I'm Miranda curve is like
definitely part of the foundation oh for
sure she's a founding member she's a
Founding Father yeah
um so congrats Ellen and Portia um and
of course congrats that the dress still
fits like that would be the biggest
thing for me that's so true are you
ready for our next story yeah
Jessica Simpson is making headlines
because she has a new book short story
out yeah movie star and I haven't read
it yet but I'm going to I just like I'm
in the middle of another book I'm only
at six percent so it's gonna be a while
guys
um and people are now speculating it's a
true story about fiction no it's true
okay it's written like a memoir yeah
like it's just like her book was it's
just like one story yeah about a time in
her life when she was separated from
Nick Lachey and she fulfills like one of
her childhood fantasies by hooking up
with a massive movie star but it turns
out like he wasn't single blah blah blah
people are trying to figure out who okay
and
there's a you know one Theory okay is
that it was Mark Wahlberg
so that's not like when I think of movie
star I don't think Mark Wahlberg really
I think Brad pitch or 20 but he isn't
like you know like he is he is so
according to Jessica she met the mystery
man at the 2001 MTV Video Music Awards
when she was on break from her future
ex-husband nicochet she said quote he
was undressing me with his eyes she told
readers of the mystery man she noted
that the mystery dude was wearing jeans
and a t-shirt Wahlberg who attended that
show that year yeah wearing jeans and a
t-shirt here he is
how many looks he was so hot when he was
young other actors who were ruled out
Will Smith Will Ferrell and Andy Dick
why they were also wearing jeans and
t-shirts yeah I bought
um or they weren't and they were at the
movie awards uh Christopher Walken Jamie
Foxx and Johnny Knoxville okay she
already like had an emotional affair
with they were all at the show too
um she said in the story that the
anonymous actor knew her trainer ripped
Mark Wahlberg is known for his workouts
in addition the Ted star was already
famous in 2001 and could have been a
childhood Crush of hers because he was
once known as Marky Mark yeah right
right did she say it was a childhood
Crush yes okay
um because he was in like you know 1992
Calvin Klein yeah like tracks with her
yeah
um and she wrote that she wound up
meeting the massive movie star again in
2006 at the Beverly Hills Hotel while he
got ready for another big awards show I
do believe
um he was in Martin's courses he's The
Departed that year and attended the
Golden Globe with his now wife who was
pregnant at the time a baby is not
mentioned in her retelling so anyways
people are piecing together when did
they sleep together at the VMAs
um I think after the VMAs like I think
they met there but is she saying that
she slept with him when he was with his
now wife that he was not single I don't
know if he was married or he was in a
relationship he might have been in a
relationship with a woman a pregnant
woman who's now his wife like right
um she needs to get more details
girlfriend like but not too many because
like you don't wanna you know she's just
trying to tell her story that was the
thing about Jessica Simpson's book is
like she actually told us everything she
went there she went there she didn't
include this in her book because she
couldn't go there until like this is a
separate book yeah where she's just like
leaving breadcrumbs yeah and she also
was like in the process of turning her
Memoir into like an Amazon series and
this is like a partnership with Amazon I
think Kindle unlimited or something so I
think it's also probably like meant to
be hypey for her future projects with
Amazon yeah but like she's now one of my
favorite authors so like she came out
with a book I'll be reading it yeah well
she said she found a journal
um yeah in her house that she like does
not remember writing and she never
thought she would like see it again and
it was like full of I guess this time
and that's what
inspired her to write this second book
yeah but I just want to say Jessica
Simpson Mark Wahlberg like I see it
I respect it I just like don't really
see her being into him because like she
was so scrupled you know literally looks
like Nick Lachey no but I mean um
personality wise like he's like from
Boston like they're so different she was
like this Bible Belt girl I feel like in
all like when you think of her
relationships maybe looks wise they're
all pretty similar but they're all like
they did different jobs like some
singers some actors some athletes
athletes like she really ran the gamut
they weren't all from where she's from
yeah I feel like she really tried to
Branch out
yeah so maybe she was in her Boston era
here her boss yeah she was definitely in
her was pop in Boston era
um so I just want to say a ship and what
could have been is I ship too young Mark
Wahlberg like is such a fun Rabbit Hole
to go down he was really kind of Next
Level handsome yeah and he's still a
cutie today he works hard yeah he's got
a good family life yeah like in his
nuclear family and like his extended
family Brothers yeah I'm always really
curious about like him and Donnie I
think it's all good
I don't know is Donnie meant to be
Johnny Drama
no I have thought that too for a while
but no so because on trash is about Mark
Wahlberg and his Entourage kind of like
very Loosely yeah but like that's the
framework but no Johnny Drama is not
like mirrored after like they're all
mirrored after real people like turtles
yeah no it's not Donnie Wahlberg but I
think a lot of people like think that
that's so funny yeah I like Johnny the
best character by far is the worst is
Chase Vinnie Chase Mark Wahlberg a drink
in the air Chase literally find me
someone more [__] annoying than
Adrian Grenier in that show couldn't
like talk about getting lucky and being
like more irresponsible and stupid no
and like just thinking you are God's
Gift oh my the show gets in fear you
really can't binge watch that show it's
like Episode by episode it's good I've
never watched the whole thing but like
Zach has watched it I've seen the movies
like I know the show I know the
characters I got the point he's [__]
infuriating he's horrible
I want to see a show about Johnny Drama
same at least he got his comeuppance
yeah like the story ends and it's like
really kind of it's like the Johnny
Drama like hero story yeah he's a hero
and his brother is the villain yeah yeah
for sure for sure
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
Perfect bar
is it it is oh my God I just got a fresh
delivery of perfect bar this morning
they must have known you were coming and
that you were gonna eat all of mine
looking for a protein bar that actually
no offense looking for a protein bar
that actually tastes good will look no
further than perfect bar with their
lineup of fresh from the fridge protein
bars perfect bar is exactly what you've
been looking for no chalky artificial
aftertaste here they're made with
freshly ground nut butter organic honey
and 20 organic superfoods perfect bar
has a variety of products like protein
bars and little snack size bars too that
are also good and good for you you are
sure to find something to love our
favorite is the dark chocolate chip
peanut butter with the sea salt it is
absolutely stunning you leave it in the
fridge because it's like so fresh and
organic that all the ingredients need to
be kept in the fridge and then you take
it out and you have like cold dark
chocolate there's really nothing better
than like a nice cold piece of dark
chocolate with a little little flaky
salt on top they have a cookie dough
texture that's creamy and full of flavor
unlike any other bars out there and now
they come in a snack size they're packed
with six grams of protein and 150
calories so a little goes a long way it
is a great thing to just throw in your
purse get a long day ahead of you it
will keep you full it's delicious and
you can sleep you know knowing they're
non-GMO project verified they're
gluten-free they're soy free they're
Kosher for all of our girlies out there
and they're low GI perfect bar knows
that it'll be Love At First Bite so for
a limited time they're offering you a
chance to try the refrigerated protein
bars for free here's how it works sign
up for email or text upload a picture of
your receipt from your local grocery
store and they will reimburse you for
the cost of one bar it'll go directly
into your venmo or your PayPal account
which is pretty cool it's pretty cool
all you have to do is go to perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today that's perfect snacks.com
toast to get a free perfect bar today
happy snacking thank you turdy yeah yeah
well our next story is a little more
Memoir documentary Making news
um a Jason because obviously Pamela
Anderson is in the news Big Time her
Memoir love Pamela came out she's in a
Netflix documentary Pamela a love story
and she's telling her story yeah now I
haven't had a chance to watch or read
her book I think I'll read her book I'm
sure it's amazing I also never watch Pam
and Tommy so I'm just like kind of out
of it but I want to get into it however
so I'm gonna withhold you know any
statements or judgment about those
things since I haven't read them
however adjacently
Tommy Lee's wife Brittany Furlan has
been slammed for a tick tock that she
posted quote mocking Pamela Anderson so
Tommy Lee is now married to Brittany
Furlan the vine which just in its own is
the crazy the craziest pop culture Twist
of all time forgotten and also they have
been married for a long time now like
they're just settled into married life
right for those who don't remember she
was really big on Vine and then she's
now just like a classic influencer she
has a bunch of tick tock followers a
bunch of Instagram followers she just
like actually sketches a comedy she's
cute I like her yeah she's really funny
and her and Tommy are happily married
it's crazy so she posted a tick tock um
using like a 90s Pam makeup filter on
herself and she did this audio and the
caption said Pam if I died so she's
pretending to be Pamela and this is the
audio it's a it's from The Wendy
Williams Show and people
um it's gone virus oh she passed away
oh
oh that's it so she was saying like like
if I died like Pam wouldn't give a [__]
you know yeah let me let Bruno out hold
on the shy guys are going crazy for this
story
you go get them bro
yes so she's saying Pam wouldn't give a
[__] um and by the way this is the
second Tick Tock she's now made
discussing
um she made another Tick Tock that was
like thank you so much to everyone who's
like reached out to me
um I guess like it is annoying for like
the culture to be obsessed with your
husband and his ex-wife mother of their
kids
um and first it was like glamorized in
Pam and Tommy and now everyone's like
obsessed with Pam because she's on like
you know she's doing Howard Stern she's
on the cover of variety so it's kind of
been like the year of Pam and it's
definitely annoying for Brittany also
from what I've seen like so much of her
Memoir and her documentary is about like
this great big love that they had you
know it's about her and Tommy yeah and I
think
that some fans might take away from that
that like they should be together yeah
and I think the way people feel long
together
[Music]
like the Open Season
sure so I think the the general takeaway
from the documentary and the book is
like you know if Pam ever wanted to get
back with Tommy like he'd be there in a
second really yeah
it's Tommy that's it's Pam that's the
holdout I think yeah anyway she deleted
the tick tock and she said before she
did like and she was getting criticism
for like mocking Pam she said please
guys I gotta make jokes it's how I cope
which like I kind of understand
um first of all she posts tick tocks
like all day every day so like now she's
in the news and this people are talking
about her husband like and she's not
gonna shy away from it she's gonna like
make a couple jokes and like she is such
a jokester like this is the joke that
she made I don't think it's that crazy I
know it's like funny and also based on
what everybody's saying about the the
love triangle like people would agree
yeah except that especially in these
last like you know five or six days when
Pam has been doing so much press she has
been asked about Brittany and she has
said like lovely things she's been very
respectful she's been super respectful
so it's not an ideal situation for like
the whole world to be like talking about
your man and his ex-wife like and just
like romanticizing it and like shipping
them it's it's unfortunate she's allowed
to deal with it in whatever way she
wants but like I think everyone is like
annoyed because we're now in this
era of protecting Pam Anderson it's like
she wasn't protected when she was young
like she was exploited you know she said
Tim Allen she flashed her
his penis like she was of course her sex
tape like she was really treated like
[__] by like by Hollywood and just the
culture and now we're protecting Pam
Anderson so like people coming after
Brittany Ferlin for this is just like a
reaction to that it's like we're not
going back there you know yeah no but I
don't think that this is going back
there it's like an over correction and
it's like Britney Ferlin making like a
funny Tick Tock saying like what
everyone's thinking about her is not the
same as Tim Allen flushing his penis
like
you're right it's an over correction now
people are just like anytime there's
anything Pam we're like stop it yeah
it's like what we did with Brittany
after everything that she's been through
like this is not sure she could handle
like a funny Tick Tock from like this is
Britney's thing right it's not like she
never posts tick tocks yeah yeah and it
would also be like a little weird if she
didn't say anything I would understand
if she didn't say anything about it but
she seems to be like an open book and
it's like Pam's talking about her nicely
like she could get in the dialogue and
this is how she communicates it's just I
can't even wrap my head around like
these three people knowing each other
like I understand why people are pressed
but I also understand how Brittany
furland thought this was a good idea
this isn't something where it's like how
could you right like how did this get
out yeah yeah what were you thinking
like she was thinking like I'm gonna
react yeah no I'm like you know cash in
at this moment you know as an influencer
you only get you know if you're lucky a
couple moments like this in your
lifetime
this moment make the most of it tomorrow
you're so vocal like singing today
yesterday is history
so why don't you be here with me
all we have is this moment
tomorrow's unspoken
yesterday we're trying to beat you
literally it's working it's working are
you ready for our fifth and final story
turdy I'm the turdy is ready our fifth
and five eternity is already the fifth
and final story on the fifth and final
day of the week it's some [__] is
what this story is I just saw your iPad
Netflix's password sharing Crackdown is
coming here's what we know so far about
how it will work Netflix so lame plan to
stop users from sharing their passwords
with each other starting to take shape
the streaming giant which last month
announced that it will soon be given the
preliminary rollout of its strategy has
updated its FAQ page with some details
about what users can expect okay the
main hurdle that Netflix will place in
front of password shares is device
verification when phones computers and
streaming devices are logged into an
account that isn't the primary user's
home network how do you know what the
home network is
they know okay like whoever made the
account whatever what if you made your
account in your old house
you took your Apple TV with you
what have you got a new TV it's still
the same Apple TV I don't know I'm just
saying like please Claudia they
literally know what you're thinking like
they know which ones they're coming okay
I just I foresee this being difficult
this will be triggered when someone
accesses your account on a new device
that isn't associated with your
household or if your account is
repeatedly being used outside of your
home Netflix will send an email to the
primary account holder with a four digit
verification code which they will have
15 minutes to enter before it expires
Netflix says that it uses IP addresses
device IDs and account activity in order
to determine which devices are part of
the same household
yeah cause like you know when I travel I
bring a Roku stick with me if my like
Hotel TV doesn't so it's like I'm always
moving around with my Netflix but your
Roku is the
but they said IP address location a
device ID that's your Roku okay and
account activity it's just like why are
they getting so bent out of shape like
you don't make enough money like this is
so greedy I'm fine with Netflix like
cracking down on password sharing you
know if you have like an X's Netflix
they don't know you're still watching it
like you keep bringing it from house to
house you shared theirs blah blah blah
like that's wrong and also one person
shouldn't be paying for all these Free
Loaders that they don't [__] know
but as long as like real family members
like the idea that like the device
verification like I'll just text the
group chat what's the verification code
like I but someone in our family was
saying that like you got a message I
think was you that you got a message and
you couldn't log into your Netflix
because there were too many people
logged in Olivia
that's a problem because we have a lot
of family we have a lot of TVs can I
tell you why they were legit I could
tell you why they're bothered by this
why because I feel like for so long like
Netflix like was posting on social media
like the you know the Netflix
um interns who run their social media
are like very in the know culture and
they're like you know when your ex's
password and they're like we're in on
the joke and like kind of encouraging
and we're like you know what that's cool
and now what the economy takes to turn
like we are victims of their greed it's
like you were all fun and games and you
were all you were our friend you were
our friends they were fun and games when
they were making billions during Copic
because we were all home having to watch
your crappy shows but now that we're all
out of the house and we also like
realize like hey like who's doing cool
stuff like Netflix is kind of trash like
they're gonna make the most of their
pounded I think about Netflix a lot like
I don't really know what just maybe like
streaming services in general like I
don't really know how it's sustainable
like Netflix is spending so much money
on like one TV show that we will watch
in three days and that's like they have
to do that what every week it's like on
a sustainable business model no that's
why this like you know and the Pendulum
is swinging and they're
tightening their belt right like I feel
like the streaming service if I had to
like put my money on a streaming service
currently
I think I would put it on like not
Disney um HBO Max because they still
have like their cable you know what I
mean like they have a lot going on
I think I would put it on like Amazon
Prime because they don't make so many of
their own shows they just like kind of
like buy up other stuff like
everything's like watchable yeah on
Prime catchy Kelsey and they have a ton
of money in the bank yeah some other
Amazon Adventures that's well but also
like Hulu was owned by designate plus
and it's like you can Mirage pretty much
anything on Amazon Prime it's something
you have to pay for and it's like if I
really want to watch something I'll pay
for it I'm glad to have the opportunity
to find it yeah but now like
it depends what kind of device you have
because if I'm really looking for
something I think I'll more likely buy
it on iTunes like on my Apple TV than I
would on Prime sending it on my computer
same
but I don't feel really strongly about
keeping it that way I mean if Amazon
wanted to do some a little more to yeah
me a great because I really don't feel
close to one platform like when I'm
looking for something to watch I
probably still start with Netflix it's
just habit yeah but I again could see
that changing soon yeah starting with
Hulu
yeah because they had Dope Sick yeah
they also had Pam and Tommy I see a lot
of you guys are watching dope sick and
your lives are being changed yeah
welcome turdy it's your turn it's my
turd yes
okay it's your turn
um it's also the end of the show and
while that is sad because like we love
doing this that is also meaning like the
weekend is that much closer lunch we
should definitely you know regroup and
discuss like you know some potential
options for lunch yeah I'll put together
like a spreadsheet and we could Circle
back on lunch options and different
variables love that guys have an amazing
weekend thank you for a great week of
toasty Vibes hope you have enjoyed
Jackson Claude back together again in
Florida thank you so much for listening
to the test the Monday Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found at Spotify
iTunes District public radio I already
cast books all the places whoever you
listen to the podcast find us the toasty
with five star review about a beautiful
stunning and
talented we are hope you guys have an
enclave a gorgeous beautiful setting and
smart weekend and we'll see you on
Monday and if you're looking for a
little extra content right now there's a
new episode of the redheads which is
fabulosity so check it out the
Magnificent lives of Marjorie post love
you bye